al'approche du second tour des élections
municipales c'est un conseil à huis clos
qui a débuté sous tension à trappes
l'ordre du jour prévoyait et trois
délibérations pour retirer les
délégations de plusieurs élus de la
majorité
parmi eux ali rabais en tête après le
premier tour
candidat face au maire sortant guy
malandain en troisième position
l'adjoint a préféré remettre sa
démission avant la tenue du vote le
concernant nous étions prêts
collectivement à travailler autour du
maire pour élaborer un certain nombre de
mesures pour travailler ensemble à la
sortie de la crise
au lieu de cela le maire a décidé
d'inscrire à l'ordre du jour le retrait
de délégation et donc le règlement de
compte avec un certain nombre d'élus qui
ont choisi de ne pas soutenir sa
cinquième candidature que nous avons
estimé à bien des égards comme la
candidature de trop et donc nous avons
décidé de ne pas participer à cela de
démissionner collectivement qu'on peut
pas faire campagne contre une personne
et une équipe et puis être délayé de
cette personne et de ses tripes ce
problème de choix d'honnêteté
intellectuelle
cet élu de la majorité en tout ont
quitté le conseil municipal du côté de
l'opposition othman nasri arrivé en
deuxième place au premier tour a bien
assisté à l'ensemble de la séance malgré
une prise de parole critique sur la
gestion de la crise sanitaire attrape
démissionner comme cela à dernière
minute n'a aucun sens alors qu'il a
approuvé 100 % des décisions pendant six
années je crois que le fait que ces
terres transmis aujourd'hui sur internet
qu'on a envie d'être dans la politique
spectacle nous nous sommes restés nous
n'avons pas quitté le conseil municipal
parce qu'ils avaient des dossiers
importants à voter pendant quatre heures
maintien du taux de la fiscalité locale
pour 2020 approbation de la convention
de la cité éducative ont été votés
pendant cette séance le conseil a
également décidé de renommer le centre
de santé municipal en hommage docteur
jacques fribourg médecins urgentistes de
l'hôpital privé de trappes décédé du
coronavirus 30 dr
pas risquer sa vie pour sauver d'autres
vies 1 voilà et et pour nous vu le
travail fait par l'hôpital et le travail
que nous nous faisons un collaboration
un partenariat que nous avons avec
l'hôpital
et puis le témoignage le tourisme est
réel 1 2 de ce monsieur sait c'est bien
c'est bien qu'on n'ait sa mémoire
lakovic 19 à bouleverser également la
vie économique
le conseil a annulé les loyers pour les
résidents de la pépinière chrysalide
pour les mois d'avril et mai